the scp foundation deals with plenty of
different groups of interest cults rival
agencies criminal organizations all of
which have some connection to anomalous
artifacts and creatures but there are
some groups of interests who actually
are responsible for the creation of
anomalies and a few are as weird and
intriguing as the dr wondertainment toy
company whether or not dr wondertainment
is a real person or not is the subject
of much speculation but whoever they are
the company that bears their name has
produced a multitude of dangerous
anomalous items that are currently in
foundation containment usually these
anomalies take the form of highly
dangerous toys but the company has also
released a very peculiar set of limited
edition creations a set of 21 living
breathing more or less human beings
known collectively as the little misters
all of them are marked by tattoos of
their name and each comes with a card
reading wow you've just found yourself
your very own little mister a limited
edition collection from dr
wondertainment find them all and become
mr collector let's take a look and see
what's out there before you try and
catch them all scp-905
or mr chameleon is a living being made
up entirely of photons his form is
described as fuzzy but definite and he
appears to be the rough shape of a human
male standing at approximately 175
centimeters in height he has no mass due
to being made solely of light particles
at least not one we can measure and
while he can move and speak he cannot
manipulate objects in the world around
him mr chameleon as his name suggests
can alter the wavelength of the light
coming from his body in order to match
the color of his environment he also has
the ability to walk through any
transparent material
scp-2287 or mr headless is a human male
who is mostly normal aside from his lack
of ahead mr headless is blind but can
somehow still speak and hear and does
not need to eat spending time around mr
headless can cause people to experience
dissociative episodes where they begin
to see themselves as headless as well in
an interview mr headless claims to have
been created for use as a halloween
decoration with his dissociative effect
on others being intended as a kind of
spooky prank even if it does sound more
like a form of torture mr headless was
found by the foundation wandering the
streets of a wisconsin town after he
left an attic where he had been kept
with other holiday decorations
scp-1799 or mr laff is a human male
standing 120 centimeters tall who has
the physical characteristics of a
classic circus clown complete with grey
and white skin a red nose and comically
long feet he is capable of communication
but everything he says will be
interpreted by those around him as a
joke no matter what he says people
around him will start to laugh and the
more he talks the more people laugh in
some cases they can even laugh
themselves to death for example one
d-class personnel used to test the
effects of mr laff started laughing so
hard that he lost his balance and
suffered a fatal cranial injury
scp-909 or mr forgetful is a man with
retrograde amnesia he appears aware of
his condition and cannot seem to recall
any of his own memories the only way
that information appears able to enter
mr forgetful's long-term memory is if he
writes it down however when he does so
something strange happens the memory
he's just written down is instantly
forgotten by anyone else who was
involved in the events
scp-3537 or mr shapi is an amorphous
humanoid that changes shape though this
transformation happens involuntarily all
of mr shapi's transformations are into
non-anomalous human beings and they have
been seen taking their own notes on
possible anomalous properties each new
persona could have they describe these
transformations as painful with the
level of pain varying dependent on how
dramatic the change is despite the pain
mr shapi says they're happy the way they
are in an interview they claim to be the
first of the little misters and their
random transformations were used as
inspiration for the appearance of all
the subsequent little mister designs
scp-1908 or mr soap is a man who
constantly produces soapy water which
will quickly fill up any area he's in
and cause all surrounding surfaces to
become slippery the soap can be easily
cleaned up with normal methods but the
levels of liquid being produced by mr
soap's body have to be constantly
monitored when the foundation discovered
him he was in a factory in china where
he had been put to work cleaning the
machinery
scp-913 or mr hungary is a middle-aged
african-american male wearing a dress
shirt and pants who is capable of eating
almost any material mr hungary is given
nutrients intravenously and must be
provided with a full day's worth of
calories every two hours or else he will
enter a hunger trance while in this
trance state he is capable of biting
with a force of up to 5000 newtons and
will devour anything and everything
around him his metabolism is so fast
that drugs and toxins have no effect on
him including amnestics and anesthesia
scp-629
or mr brass is a massive brass automaton
standing at 170 centimeters and weighing
500 kilograms all parts of mr brass's
body are removable and can be rearranged
with only mild discomfort to mr brass
himself projections show that there are
at least 73 billion possible
combinations of mr brass's body parts
when mr brass was discovered by the
foundation he had been taken in by the
church of the broken god who believed
him to be a religious idol and worshiped
him as a deity
scp-644 or mr hot is a man who can both
accurately guess the number of children
that any person has biological or
otherwise and predict the material
wishes of any child he also claims to be
able to accurately predict the
popularity of any product aimed at
children when approached he will offer a
business card that identifies him as dr
wondertainment's marketing consultant he
was found sleeping in the hallway of a
school in racine wisconsin a town that
was later found to contain many children
with anomalous wondertainment toys in
their possession in interviews mr hot
describes his job as being able to
identify which children would get the
most use out of a wondertainment toy in
his own words you can't just give this
kind of craftsmanship to just anybody
you give the average kid a realistic
race car he's just gonna go leave it on
a shelf and go stare at the sun or
something
scp-2396 or miss sweetie is a female
humanoid who stands at 250 centimeters
tall and weighs 101 kilograms she lives
entirely on sugar and foods containing
sugar and claims to be in pain when
denied her sweet fuel she has a
repellent effect on males a feature
which she says is meant to keep nasty
brothers and their friends out anomalous
hard candies will appear at random
anywhere in a six kilometer radius of
miss sweetie's location when ingested by
females the candies are perfectly
harmless but any masculine presenting
humans who eat them start to undergo
transformation into a being made
entirely of living candy these candy
entities are resistant to blunt force
trauma but can be easily dispatched with
fire and will obey any command given to
them by any person who identifies as
female
scp-1000
or mr life is a male humanoid who goes
through the entire human life cycle
every 75 minutes aging at a rate of one
year per minute mr life has a key hole
in his back that when a key is inserted
into it can reverse the aging process
each turn of the key regresses mr life
one year younger until he's fully
regressed to a newborn baby mr life was
seized from a california mansion after
he had been purchased at an auction held
by marshall carter and dark limited
another group of interests that provides
the wealthiest and most powerful people
in the world with objects and
experiences that would otherwise be
impossible without the help of the
anomalies they trade in other little
misters were also sold at the auction
though the buyer of mr life couldn't
recall who they were or exactly which
little misters they had bought the
tattoo on mr life's back reads mr life
and mr death which may imply that mr
life has a counterpart that the
foundation has not yet been able to
identify
scp-527 or mr fish is a non-anomalous
man with no physical abnormalities of
any kind save for the fact that he has
the head of a fish he was discovered in
boston in 2002 and moved to site 19 in
2004. in his initial interview with
foundation researcher dr baker mr fish
was very frank and upfront about his
lack of interesting qualities like i
told the other guy this is all it is
you're looking at it lies thrives hot
sweetie they got all the good stuff i'm
just the guy with the fish head
scp-917 or mr moon is an elderly man
whose facial features wax and wane in
time with the lunar cycle on nights when
the moon is full his face is normal and
his face is completely blank on nights
with a new moon this is painless for mr
moon but he does lose his sense of sight
hearing and smell when his face is in
its new moon state and he claims that
the experience leaves him very tired
scp-2855 or mr money is a latin american
man who is anomalously affected by any
business transactions regarding his
ownership as soon as any person
exchanges money for ownership of mr
money and creates any kind of written
proof of that ownership mr money will be
teleported to their location mr money's
abilities are also subject to the
beliefs of whoever claims ownership of
him and will display any anomalous
properties that are written as part of
his contract mr money was recovered in
2007 taken from the holdings of marshall
carter and dark llp a branch of the same
company that had previously sold mr life
when mr money was discovered mcnd had
been selling and buying him back
repeatedly in order to test his adaptive
capabilities scp-920
or mr lost is an asian man in a green
hoodie who seems to do nothing but
wander aimlessly transportation and
containment of mr lost are impossible as
any attempts to do so can result in a
variety of natural disasters and other
destructive phenomena he has a kind of
psychic pull on those around him who
feel compelled to walk and talk with him
mr loss doesn't seem to suffer from any
environmental effects as he has been
spotted wandering deserts and tundra
with no apparent harm coming to him
whatsoever scp-2284
or mr y is a man of indian descent whose
voice has a cognito hazardous effect on
anyone who hears it any statement that
mr lai says will be perceived as true
despite the fact that mr lai is
physically incapable of telling the
truth because of this mr lie
communicates mainly via rhetorical
questions which is the only way he can
express what he means
scp-2428-1 or mr madd is a man in a
multi-colored straitjacket who can only
be seen by those possessing the document
designated scp-2428
a document which serves as proof of
purchase mr madd is essentially an
imaginary friend who can only be seen by
the lone person in possession of the
scp-2428 document in interviews mr madd
expresses a belief that he was a real
person once before being rendered
imaginary by dr wondertainment in fact
there is evidence to suggest many of the
little misters were once ordinary people
scp-2933 is a partially submerged steel
structure located in a saltwater
reservoir a structure which contains
scp-2933-a
or mr scary the interior of
scp-2933 is constantly changing and
seems to move and shift in a way that
directs anyone who enters towards mr
scary once inside the structure there is
no way back to the entrance despite his
name and despite the sense of dread
surrounding the steel structure mr scary
doesn't seem interested in scaring
people he self-identifies as mr smiles
and seems to have the personality of a
young child his body is like his
containment covered in rust a condition
which he claims was transferred to him
by his father and which he says is very
painful while he does have a tattoo
naming him mr smiles a rusted patch of
his skin appears to have been marked
with mr scary property of the factory
suggesting that they may have had
something to do with his rusted
condition
scp-2148 or mr stripes is a man wearing
a white blindfold if the blindfold is
removed anything that mr stripes tries
to commit to memory whether that's a
passage of text a scene from a movie or
a person's face becomes censored by
large black bars in all existing records
mr stripes refers to mr ly as his
brother and believes himself to be the
first little mister although he was told
that by mr lye so take it with a grain
of salt based on mr stripe's testimony
mr ly spent a lot of time with him
traveling around and making use of their
combined abilities to break into secure
government buildings even though they
were close mr stripes has never directly
looked at mr lye as he tells it dr
wondertainment told him they weren't
supposed to look at mr la yet and then
last but not least is mr redd who has
not been given a designation and is
listed as a discontinued little mister
his story is a topic that would take an
entire video to explain altogether but
he may just be the most violent powerful
and dangerous of all the little misters
as interesting as the little misters are
they're not the only anomalous creatures
of the mysterious dr wondertainment so
let us know in the comments if you'd
like to hear more about this twisted toy
maker after all nothing makes you feel
more like a child at heart than running
in terror from a dr wondertainment
original now check out scp-3082
neverland's lost boys and girls and
scp-3008 trapped in ikea for more
strangeness from the world of the scp
foundation